[Musique]
surveillant comme on respecte un
enseignant est-ce que c'est clair c'est
pas
nouveau professeur de mathématiques
pour Pronote quelqu'un pour me montrer
bien sûr je te montre à la récréation si
tu veux moi aussi je peux te montrer à
la recrute après ou avant la récré OK
ne fera jamais d'études longues mais
finalement je me débrouille
ça va mieux
[Musique]
de savoir ce qui va pas
s'emmerde et moi aussi je m'emmerde je
crois que tu sais mais en fait je sais
pas le pire c'est que tu sais même pas
que tu sais pas expliquer ce que tu sais
on distingue deux grandes catégories de
vol
[Musique]
cans était
assez ennuyeux
[Musique]
mon père j'ai échoué
mes études je faisais du surf à Biarritz
il arrive quand tu es balancé dans un
collège et puis tu découvres que tu es à
ta place
[Musique]
c'est le mardi
voilà